you have reached the Josephine County
Sheriff's Office due to limited staffing
we are unable to answer your call
transferring to an attendant one moment
please your call cannot be completed at
this time please try again later goodbye
Josephine County is a rural area in
southwestern Oregon with a population of
around 80,000 people a lot of people are
struggling in this area because of the
lack of employment I think the most
common crimes that we're seeing or
burglaries burglaries and theft's due to
a massive budget shortfall Josephine
County has had to reduce its public
safety expenditures from 20 million
dollars last year to less than 9 million
dollars this year by year ago we had we
were up to 98 personnel and we ran out
39 we now have three patrol officers to
cover 1642 square miles we only work one
eight-hour shift five days a week in May
of 2012 cuts to the county jail staff
led to the release of 39 inmates
including people charged with robbery
assault and rape when they left here
they were laughing and joking and having
a good time and they went right back to
what they do best and that's you know
create victims basically we only respond
to life threatening calls property
crimes we don't do any follow-up we just
don't have the personnel to do it we're
seeing a lot more victims people are
getting more and more angry some people
are taking the law into their own hands
which obviously scares the heck out of
me they will not send an officer out so
we are on our own totally for
self-protection I carry a Glock
nine-millimeter semi-automatic Sam
Nichols co-founded citizens against
crime in the summer of 2012 we had our
first very first meeting the first part
of August and at the neighborhood fire
station and in the small town of O'Brien
we had 100 people show up to our very
first meeting that's amazing since then
Nichols and a group of around 20 armed
volunteers have been conducting routine
patrols in and around O'Brien Oregon the
blinking light that's on top of the car
is always on whether
the daytime or night so that it
identifies us because we do drive slowly
this is a problem house right here if
you call it that
for the most part the patrols are boring
and we hope to keep them that way
being out there enough that people don't
try to do so the criminal is going to
pick on the vulnerable you know the
Sheep I and if he sees a weak area
that's where he's going to penetrate my
biggest tool when we go out as a
notebook and a pen and a cell phone and
my eyes the gun is secondary or tertiary
or even further down the load the list
than that we don't want something to
happen that happened in Florida the case
where Zimmerman shot the boy
our patrols are always a minimum of two
people in six months of patrolling we
have not had a reported theft in our
area that says something for our patrol
what Sam is doing is it's admirable in
in one sense and I just hope that they
they don't make a mistake I you know I
admire him for stepping up to the plate
former deputy sheriff carol dixon is
another josephine county residents who
is stepping up to the plate i was
talking to one of my law enforcement
friends and i was joking and i said we
need to start a Facebook page that we
can post when things are stolen or when
somebody's house was burglarized Dixon
started a Facebook page called to catch
a thief in July of 2012 today the site
has more than 1,600 followers it's like
a virtual neighborhood watch it's all
public information it's just a central
clearinghouse where people in this
valley can go and look and see what's
going on in the neighborhood and be more
aware so they're not the next victim
it's law enforcement can use this site
to and they have here unlike so many
other cash-strapped counties in the u.s.
Josephine counties financial problems
stem from a long and complicated
relationship with the federal government
the problem that I think is unique to
our county is a lot of the land in our
county is owned by the federal
government no taxes are generated by
that in 1916 the federal government
purchased nearly 3 million acres of land
in Oregon that had been owned by the
railroads as a result 18 counties in
Oregon lost a significant source of
property tax revenue to make up for the
loss of property taxes Congress
eventually passed something called the
onc Act of nineteen thirty-seven the
federal government says okay we will
give you fifty percent of the timber
revenues well over the years that worked
until the environmentalists stopped the
logging and we no longer got that in the
1990s congress authorized temporary
subsidies to compensate counties for the
lost timber revenue
over the last four years was the
drawdown last year we got our last check
and so now the federal government
controls our land we can't use for any
resources and they've turned their back
on us and walk away kind of a typical
federal methodology we are going to need
to be out there for at least the next
five years in my opinion people need to
band together now more so than ever to
protect each other because law
enforcement here in this community is
weak at best maybe we've become too
dependent on the government for
everything we outnumber the people that
are causing these crimes by at least 98
99 to one or two if we stand shoulder to
shoulder we can take back our community
and we have done that